all right Kate hi hey uh where are you
from originally where'd you grow up I'm
from Baton Rouge Louisiana
um about an hour from New Orleans tell
me about your your childhood growing up
um so I was born my dad was away for the
entire my mom's entire pregnancy with me
in Singapore
um he was working over there so I think
that created tension between them and
they were divorced by the time I was
two months old
so my mom I was mostly with my mom
because I was an infant and then as I
got like a little bit older and was able
to be away from my mom more I would go
and stay with my dad so it was
half and half back and forth for my
whole life and their divorce never
really bothered me because I was so
young and they're so they're Polar
Opposites and so I really don't know how
they ever even were married
I'm glad they got divorced and
I didn't have a problem with growing up
and split households
um
when
I was about three or four my dad met a
woman
um can I say her name
like her first name sure okay her name's
Elle
um and she
quickly got pregnant with my sister
and then just as quickly revealed that
she was extremely problematic
um
she would break into our house she would
um
threaten us threaten my mom
um
threatens blame me and my mom for the
reason that my dad wouldn't marry her
because my dad was not going to marry
her she was around mostly because she
was pregnant with my dad's child and he
wasn't going to kick her to the curb you
know
um
she did move in with my dad and my mom
kind of tried to keep me away
from her as much as possible but you
know you can't
my dad still had custody over me to a
certain extent so like she couldn't just
stop me from seeing him and Elle had
another a daughter from another
um guy
um who was a little bit older than me
and I can't really remember how much
older I can't really remember
specifics of a lot of my childhood
um but she she did start molesting me
the daughter
um so that was going on at my dad's
house
I want to say she was like eight or nine
when that started and I was like four so
like five years older than me
um and she was also
um I believe being molested at her
maternal grandfather's house but I don't
have like proof of that or anything but
the maternal grandfather is a convicted
pet file so
you know and children don't just start
doing that they learn it from somewhere
so
that started happening
um over there
um my sister was born
they lived with us for a little while
um
probably so my sister was like one or
two
and then
they moved out because
it was just craziness just all the time
like
it was I mean her daughter would destroy
everything there was pee on everything
there was vomit on everything she would
break everything she was molesting me
which my dad didn't know about no one
knew about that for a while
um
and I think that's kind of what
kick-started my OCD
um
was that molestation and holding it in
and I've always been extremely anxious I
cried every single day of school until
probably fourth grade and embarrassingly
long time
um I never I did not want to be away
from my parents specifically my mom
um
and so it was just I don't know the
whole situation with L and my childhood
just created this ball of anxiety
um that I still carry around to this day
um
so that was really hard
um her daughter eventually
got moved away to some other state and
like went and lived with cousins or
something and I after I eventually told
my mom of the abuse I never saw her
again and it was never acknowledged
really by them it was acknowledged by my
mom I got into therapy and stuff
and that's when
um some OCD Tendencies started so
every single night
I would
before I went to bed I would go up to my
mom and I would say
it's okay and it wasn't my fault right
every single night
um
and
I was like five or six
um and then along with that I started
having like suicidal obsessions at that
age I was really morbid child it was
probably really scary for my parents
they probably were like what the hell is
going on with this child but
um
a common thing with obsessive-compulsive
disorder is intrusive thoughts so
um I would get intrusive thoughts
that would be like
um jump off of this balcony that you're
walking on and things like that and I
was so young and it was scary
um and I would like tell my mom and
she'd be like okay well we're not gonna
do that but it just it wouldn't it's
like the thoughts would stick to my
brain like a broken record almost and
over and over and over it would just be
like jump off the balcony jump off the
balcony what would happen if you jumped
off the balcony
um so I would have obsessions like that
um
I had obsessions where I had my
underwear had to be really tight and I
used to like sneak and wear swimsuits
under my clothes because I wanted my
underwear to be like basically cutting
off my circulation same thing with my
socks and my socks had to be pulled all
the way up like at all times so
constantly all day at school I don't
even think I walked upright I just
constantly was like
pulling my socks up and down all day
long
um
so those were like the early signs that
I had OCD just like asking questions
um like wanting things to feel right
um which is really common and then I
went to Catholic School my whole life
um so that was another Obsession that I
had
um was praying so I would say
an absurd amount of our fathers and then
I follow that with an equally as absurd
but less amount of Hail Marys so like
let's say I would do 20 our fathers and
then I would do 10 Hail Mary's and then
I would do five Glory bees and if I
wasn't paying attention
um I have to start over so like if I
found myself drifting off and not um
focusing on every single word I'd have
to start over and I would just stay up
all night doing that
um and like making the sign of the cross
at the end of it
at the end of each prayer if it didn't
feel right on my forehead
then I had to keep doing it until it
felt right and then I could move on to
the next prayer
um
so
um I think it was always hardwired in my
brain my aunt on my dad's side has
obsessive compulsive disorder
um
but I think the molestation is what kind
of triggered it in me so young
um
so I went to therapy for the mail
station
um
and
the OCD wasn't really addressed in
therapy that I can remember
and I completed that and I was doing
well I also was on
antidepressants when I was like seven
um and I was on those probably until
I was like nine
um and I had panic attacks this whole
time as well where I would go into these
states of like derealization
um
just like not feeling
real feeling like everything around me
was a dream feeling like completely
removed from reality and it would feel
almost like
if in your everyday life you have a veil
on it would feel like the veil came off
and I was almost in like
a simulation I don't know how to
describe it but it's a common thing with
OCD which I know now but I did not know
then so then I was like I'm going crazy
and I would start panicking and freaking
out and I called those panic attacks uh
bad feelings so tell my mom like I'm
having bad feelings
um and I think back now it's it's really
sad because or it's sad to me because
it's like I didn't have the language
to describe what I was going through
and it was just that makes it harder I
find when like you have a label to put
on something it makes it easier at least
to identify like well this is what I'm
experiencing
um so
anyway things kind of settle down for a
while like
I would say throughout middle school and
then Junior High and then
early High School I was fine and I kind
of thought I didn't have anxiety anymore
um
I
can't think of any OCD Tendencies I had
like it kind of
felt like it just went away
um and it was like
something
distant in my childhood that I dealt
with and I just chalked it up to I was
being molested and then I went to
therapy and the therapy fixed it and now
I'm better because they never talk to me
about having OCD my mom would talk to my
therapist and be like you know I think
she has OCD she's like asking me the
same questions over and over and she's
doing all these things and I would say I
had a pretty big fear of like being
abandoned and no matter how many times
they told me like I'm gonna pick you up
from school don't worry it didn't stick
like
it just it didn't stick it was OCD is
the doubting disease so
it's like no matter what anyone told me
it's like but what if but what if but
what if and no amount of reassurance is
Ever Enough
um
so
now I'm in high school
um and some things
start popping up again very suddenly and
it was really scary and I remember
so I'm experiencing things with boys
right I have little boyfriends and I'm
um kissing boys for the first time and
whatever I'm like 14 or 15. and I start
being very hypersexual
um which now I know is a comment I mean
it's common with people that have gotten
molested
um
so I started being really hypersexual
not thinking it mattered not thinking it
bothered me
um
and I wasn't doing anything that was
necessarily out of the ordinary like it
wasn't like I was having sex when I was
13 and 14 years old but it was
um just talking to a lot of boys
in ways I probably shouldn't have been
and going to the movies with all these
boys and like making out with them and
whatever and things my mom would not
have been wanting me to do but
um
I woke up one day and had this like
intense feeling of dread in me that if I
did not tell my mom every sexual
experience I had been having I don't
know what was going to happen I just had
this awful feeling I was panicking I was
throwing up I was shaking and I just had
this thing it's like a light bulb went
off that it was like if you tell your
mom
all if you confess all of this stuff to
her that you've been doing
um this feeling will go away
so I did which is extremely humiliating
to tell your parent
something like that and she doesn't want
to know either like she didn't want to
know that stuff
um but I didn't care
um and I told her all these things and I
was like
okay got it off my chest it's done the
hard part's over wrong
um I did that I told my mom every sexual
experience I had
probably until
I was 18 or 19.
so that goes into having sex and doing
other things with people intimate things
with people
um I started having sex when I was 15. I
told my mom immediately after it
happened I started freaking out and told
my mom like not even 10 minutes after it
happened I walked in the door and I told
my mom first thing I did
so it became an obsessive-compulsive
cycle where the obsession was
sex anything sex related I felt like I
was doing something really wrong
um and dirty and
and I needed to tell my mom and that was
a compulsion and my mom became
my compulsion
um
and
if I didn't think she understood I would
tell her again
the same thing and if I if I thought she
forgot or she wasn't listening I would
tell her again
um
and sometimes I would try not to tell
her but I would try to replace this
obsessive-compulsive cycle with another
one so I would try to be like
you don't want to know right
so that was my compulsion I would ask
her you don't want to know right like
you don't want to know these things I'm
doing with these boys and she would say
no but that wasn't ever enough I would
eventually have to tell her
um
that's how a CD is It's never enough
like you think
okay I'm just gonna ask her this
question I'm going to do the compulsion
and then I'm going to feel better but
it's never enough it's
it's almost like an addiction in the
sense that the more you do it the more
you have to do it and it makes you feel
good for that however long of time that
you feel relief
um but it's going to come back and it's
going to come back stronger
because you're reinforcing that these
thoughts are dangerous and that
something needs to be done about them
so that happened for a really long time
and then on top of that I would have to
tell the boy that I told my mom
which was awful because they didn't
understand and 15 year old boys and 16
year old boys don't care what OCD is and
nor do they understand and I really
didn't understand
um so
that was really really hard for
all of my relationships I basically
destroyed them because there was no
sense of like
trust I guess it was like well you're
gonna tell your mom and I would and I
felt like I couldn't control it
um
so yeah that went on for a while and I
went back to therapy and the thing about
OCD is
um
there's a specific type of therapy to
treat OCD called exposure exposure
response prevention
um and that's not the kind of therapy I
was getting I was just getting like the
cognitive behavioral therapy which is
what most therapists who treat like
anxiety and depression will use
um
so yeah I was not getting the treatment
that I needed and I don't think that was
anyone's fault necessarily
um I was misdiagnosed as having
generalized anxiety disorder which is
common with people with OCD that is not
what I had and they that's what they
were treating so it wasn't working they
would tell me Well replace your bad
thought with a different thought
it doesn't work that way
um
I used to call my obsessive thoughts
sticky thoughts because it's literally
like someone's super glued a thought to
your brain and that's all you're
thinking about and it will not go away
it will not relent it's like you have
headphones on that you can't take off
and the thought is on repeat so it's
like replacing that thought is not an
option
um
so
none of that really helped me
um
throughout high school and things like
that I just kept on
doing all these things just confessing
but I never stopped being hypersexual
though either it's like it wasn't the
discomfort of having to confess to my
mom wasn't enough
um
for me to want to stop
doing these things with these boys and I
I thought I had
worked through
the molestation so I didn't even put two
and two together that that was probably
what was happening that I had worked
through it as a child but that it had
it's claws in me and it was going to
follow me into adulthood
um
so
my mom got pregnant my mom remarried a
woman who when I was probably like eight
so she's
a mother figure to me as well
um
and they had a baby
um
and my mom being a lesbian was a really
big secret because I went to a Catholic
School in the South and being gay was a
joke
to everybody
um like if you were gay it was like the
worst thing in the world so I was not
about to let anyone know that my mom was
gay so I would lie to everyone and say
that her wife was actually just like our
cousin or my aunt or something like that
and that the guy she got pregnant with
was traveling or whatever like I would
just lie to all my friends and just not
there was no way anyone was going to
find out
um and they knew like of course they
knew because that's your cousin doesn't
come in town and then live with you
forever and sleep in the same bed as
your mom like that doesn't make any
sense but I thought I was fooling
everyone and that was a really big point
of anxiety for me that everyone was
going to find out and my mom never
really talked to me about it
um
so it was kind of me just figuring it
out on my own and not really
understanding I was like well she
married a man and she had a baby with a
man so she can't be gay it was just
really confusing
um
so that was a big point of anxiety for
me and then she got pregnant
and that was like devastating to me
because I was like okay well now I kind
of have to
deal with
this I have to find a way to explain
this to people
um
and that was really really hard but that
was also when my OCD started
um with the pedophilic intrusive
thoughts
was when my sister was born so I would
just have these thoughts that what if
I'm a pedophile and I just don't know it
um and I found that OCD targets things
that you care about the most
so my sister was born and I was 13 when
she was born she's way younger than me
so I kind of felt like this motherly
sense of like I need to protect her and
stuff and so that's when my OCD started
with
um well you're a pedophile
um
and I would
to like
check if that was true
I would have a thought in my mind like I
would picture a naked child for example
and I would check how my body felt when
I thought of a naked child I was like am
I feeling aroused
well what if I am well am I and then I
would sit there and I would just like
over and over and over in my head just
try to figure out if I was feeling
aroused or not
um
and it it was it became like she wanted
me to braid her hair and I didn't want
to touch her at all because I was scared
that
something bad was gonna happen and
it was completely against all my morals
and all of my values
um and it was the most terrifying
thought in the world to me was that I
was a pedophile and there was nothing I
could do about it
um and I'm not a pedophile which is
what
like
that's the scariest part about OCD is it
makes you try to think that you're
something that you're not
um
and that you're going to lose everything
that is most important to you because
you're this monster and you're this bad
person and you're going to do all these
bad things
so it was my main Obsession for a while
and my compulsion continued to be
telling my mom
so anytime I had any sort of thought
um that was like sexual or pedophilic in
nature I told my mom and I would get
thought it almost feels like I had a
little person living in the back of my
mind
he was just yelling of seeing things at
me throughout the day
like I would just be minding my business
um doing school or something and in the
back of my head I would be like you want
to [ __ ] a kid
and it's just really disturbing and it's
on repeat and there it felt like there
was nothing I could do to get out my
head
except for tell my mom like I'm having
these thoughts
and luckily my mom is a social worker
um and she loves me very much and cares
about me very much and was doing her own
research
and pedophilic obsessions are really
common with OCD
which I did not know at the time but
um she kind of knew so she would assure
me which wasn't helping the problem but
what do you do like when
somebody
you love and care about your child is
coming to you in pain and is is telling
you like hey you can relieve my pain
even if
she knew that it was just enabling me I
think but when I'm crying having panic
attacks and thinking that I'm a bad
person and a pedophile I mean she's
gonna
tell me no you're not these are all the
reasons you're not you're not and that
just reinforces the thought for OCD that
it's a dangerous thought that I need to
go talk to my mom about or else it's
going to become true
so that was really really hard because
thinking you're a pedophile I mean you
can't you can't just go tell people that
like they're not going to understand if
you just if you're just talking to
someone and you're like well I'm having
these pedophilic thoughts
they're going to assume that they're
true
and that they're real but a thought is
just a thought it isn't
fact or reality so
yeah that um
that was a really hard idea for me to
grasp that my thoughts weren't who I am
they're just thoughts but I mean it
would be constant like if I saw a kid in
a grocery store if I saw a photo of a
kid if I saw a kid on TV I mean kids are
everywhere and it would just constantly
be like you want to do this with this
child you want to do this with this
child and it would be graphic sometimes
sometimes it would just be like a
reminder like remember you could be a
pedophile
um
and I would fight with it and I just
felt like I had nowhere to go like you
can't tell people that I would tell that
to my mom and that was it and it felt
like a reality like an actual
there was an actual chance that I could
be
and there was no escaping it
um
it's like a really hard feeling
to describe that someone you never acted
on it no never it was it wasn't even
that you were aroused by it it was more
that you were just afraid that you might
be yeah yeah I never acted on it
um that horrified me like that I would
act on it I would be horrified that I
would sleep walk and molest someone and
then not know that I had done it
um
I would also be scared I would sleepwalk
and hurt someone or hurt myself
um
and have no control over it so that kind
of became obsessive things I became
obsessed that my mom was gonna kill me
and hurt me so I would every single
night before bed so that was my
obsession right that was my thought
the thing I was scared of and would
obsess on so my compulsion was every
single night before bed I would tell my
mom I would be like
you know I feel really sick and my
stomach hurts really bad so don't come
in my room and don't don't bother me
because as if that would stop her from
killing me if she really wanted to kill
me but I would tell her you know I'm not
feeling well so just stay out of my room
and just like don't touch me and don't
touch my bed and just like leave me
alone because I was scared that she was
going to hurt me
um I had like no supervision at my dad's
house as a child so I watched whatever I
wanted and kind of did whatever I wanted
and was exposed to like
my dad would let us watch like really
scary movies and stuff when I was little
and like watch the news and stuff so I
would see parents that had killed their
children like I remember I watched the
entire Casey Anthony trial on tv when I
was like 10.
um so that kind of scared the [ __ ] out
of me and became like an obsessive thing
that
um my parents were gonna hurt me and
like my dad was going to pick me up from
school one day and we were going to be
driving and all of a sudden I was gonna
look out the window not recognize where
we were and he was taking me to kill me
somewhere and it was really scary and no
matter how much I
would kind of use evidence to be like
no that's not going to happen nothing
like that has ever happened your parents
have never hurt you or said anything to
make you think they're going to hurt you
it didn't matter because it was like but
what if they do and you're just not
gonna know no one knows their parents
are going to hurt them so why would you
know and it's like this fight going on
in my own brain back and forth
um
and some things were only obsessions
that didn't have compulsions attached to
them which is called Pure o
um so it was just purely an obsession
and that was one of them
um
but yeah the pedophile thing the hurting
people thing I was just like had this
intense fear that
I was
gonna hurt someone or molest someone or
whatever
and that was really hard to go through
because I don't
I just didn't have the proper treatment
um
no one really knew what to do I don't
think
like none of the therapists were really
trained in OCD so they were just telling
me
you know use evidence-based thinking to
back up why you're not
a dangerous person
but it doesn't work that way because the
for every single point you have on your
list of evidence of why you're not a
dangerous person OCD is going to come
back and give you a reason why that
could not be true why it's going to try
to debunk every single thing on the list
and it's stronger it's really I mean
it's strong it's like
it feels like you have no choice like
have you ever have you ever seen the
movie um Ella Enchanted
it's just about this girl who has like a
um a spell put on her and so she has to
do what people tell her and then she
falls in love with this guy and he's a
prince and
um someone tells her like she needs to
kill the prince because they like want
to be in power and she
has to do it and it's awful and
horrifying to her because that's the
person that she loves the most
so that's kind of what OCD feels like to
me is like you know you're hurting
people around you I knew I was putting
my mom in psychological distress I knew
I was ruining my
like high school boyfriend relationships
I I knew I was like isolating myself in
these ways and it just felt like I
couldn't stop
um
and I would get in fights with my
friends because if I said one
if I said something bad about a friend
or something that wasn't even bad it was
I could say oh so-and-so's in a bad mood
today and then my brain would be like
well you just [ __ ] talk to your best
friend
and then I'd have to go tell them that I
should talk to them even though I didn't
really [ __ ] talk them at all so then
after I told them hey I [ __ ] talked to
you
I would have to then say but I I didn't
really [ __ ] talk you it was mostly
um I just said this you know but then
they would be upset with me because
people don't understand they didn't
understand like what I was saying which
isn't their fault
but it was really hard
um
how old are you now I'm 24. 24. yeah has
it improved since
so you're working
I am working
I have my call I have a degree I want to
go back to school
and get my Master's in social work
um
it improved slightly
in my late teens early 20s
and then the existential anxiety began
so
um I was actually hospitalized because I
quit eating and I quit sleeping entirely
because I don't I don't know what
triggered this I woke up one day and I
realized that I was going to die and I
could die at any moment and everyone
around me was going to die and
everything I loved would one day be gone
and I had no control over that
and I think a really big thing for my
OCD at least and I'm I'm sure it's
common
across the board
but is control like I want to know
what's going to happen I don't want any
uncertainty I don't want any doubt I
want to know what's going to happen
um so I would just get online and Google
for hours
um about the afterlife and get on these
like weird subreddits and these weird
places on the internet of all these
people like debating what happens when
we die and I would just freak out
because there was no answer it was like
the ultimate it was like the Pinnacle of
everything I had struggled with up to
this moment
because for example like if you're a
pedophile the answer is either yes or no
you either are or you aren't with
death and existential questions there's
no answer
so I just got completely stuck
um I couldn't
I couldn't function so I went to the
mental hospital
which was horrible
they didn't help me at all
they basically just put you on a bunch
of medications and uh make sure you're
not going to kill yourself and then they
send you back out into the world
um
so yeah I was there for about a week
um
I had a boyfriend at the time I would
constantly tell him I think I cheated on
you
and I don't remember
um so that was really hard because he
wasn't really understanding what was
going on and that was just my OCD
putting things into my mind like I'd
make eye contact with a boy
and I would be like oh I was flirting
with him and then I'd have to tell my
boyfriend I was flirting with this boy
and then backtrack and be like but it
wasn't really flirting with him and it
was just my relationship was suffering
and I was with that boy for like two
years so I mean it was that was really
hard on him
um and you weren't cheating on him no
you were telling him that you were yeah
because well I was like I'm scared I did
do you consider this cheating I I looked
at I made eye contact with a boy
um in the store and what if what if I
had lust in my eyes what if what if I
was like
telling him with my eyes that I I wanted
to have sex with him like that's
cheating so now I have to go tell this
person that I that I like was flirting
with this person and trying to Allure
them and and I'm this like awful Harlot
that is trying to
like run around on my boyfriend and I
wasn't like I adored my boyfriend and
that's just another example of OCD like
just taking something that you love and
you care about and
trying to kind of dismantle it and ruin
it
um but the existential thing was my
biggest
challenge yet and it still is
um
it's like this road like all my problems
with OCD I've been able to get over
to a certain extent I still can't lie to
people if I lie to someone I immediately
confess that I lied
some of the most honest person in the
world by by force that's a great quality
yeah I guess so but I don't have a
choice so
um and I would like get in trouble at
school or something they would think I
was cheating and my mom would come in
and be like she can't lie like she's not
lying she can't lie
and people just it just it wasn't like
clicking because
when people think OCD they think oh
you're really cleanly you like to wash
your hands you like things organized no
maybe for some people that have like
contamination
obsessions or
um like germ obsessions or whatever
that's their problem or a really common
compulsion is like flicking light
switches but like I said that's a common
compulsion there are a lot of
compulsions that are really uncommon
like being afraid you're gonna hurt
someone being afraid that you're a
murderer or a pedophile whatever I I
still get intrusive thoughts to this day
I have a dog who I adore with all my
heart it's just me and her against the
world and I'll randomly get an intrusive
thought that's like you want to [ __ ]
your dog
you know you do you know you do and I'll
get these graphic
images in my mind of bestiality
and I'm better now at ignoring them
um
and not letting it bother me because I'm
like okay [ __ ] off like I know that's my
OCD and I just tell it to
I just I'm like whatever I'm not giving
any weight to that thought because I
know it's not true
um but if you don't know what OCD is and
all of a sudden you have thought in your
brain that's like you want to [ __ ] your
pet it's like what the hell
it's really scary and you don't really
know where to go with that because you
can't just tell like your significant
other or your friend like hey I had this
really scary thought that I wanted to do
this horrific thing like
because then they're gonna be like what
because they're they're not having those
intrusive thoughts
um
I mean people do have intrusive thoughts
like if you've ever had a thought like
what if I just drove my car off the
bridge that's an intrusive thought but
you're able to move on from it and
people with OCD aren't able to move on
from it they then become why am I
suicidal what if I'm suicidal what if I
jerk my arm without what if I lose
control and drive my car off the bridge
and kill myself and everyone's going to
think I was suicidal and I wasn't and it
becomes this like big story line in your
head of what if what if what if and
you're trying to find ways to like get
out of it or find relief or prove to
yourself that it's not that that's not
your reality to like the compulsion
almost provides safety
um
like when people check if their stove is
off one million times it's because they
want to feel safe
that their house isn't going to burn
down while they're sleeping
and it's almost like you have a logical
side and then your OCD side logically I
know
that I'm not a dangerous person I've
never hurt anyone I don't want to hurt
people
I don't want to hurt animals I don't
want to hurt myself
um but then the OCD side is like but
what if you do
and it just goes from there and you do
the compulsions to kind of quiet the OCD
side but ultimately it just builds it up
it's just backwards but the existential
thing has been something I'm I haven't
I've gotten better with it
um
I don't Google anymore which is good
because that was like a major compulsion
I mean you're wondering how and if
you're going to die oh yeah I would just
get constantly every single day that's
pretty much like what I
think about old people trigger me a lot
I get really sad when I see old people I
get
because it's just kind of like looking
in a mirror of like that's going to be
me one day
and like losing your faculties and
things like that I just
I just freak out but the thing is like
my grandfather died
and I thought okay when someone close to
me dies it's gonna be the end I'll be
all I'm going to be in a psych ward for
the rest of my life I'm not going to be
able to handle it but then it actually
happened
and I handled it really really well like
a like normally I would say I
experienced grief and I was upset but
I wasn't
trying to figure out
what happened to him when he died you
know I wasn't trying to
to find the answers to it it's like when
things the anxiety is much worse than
the actual
event
um but yeah a lot I think like ever even
driving over here I was just thinking
like oh an 18 wheeler could hit me right
now and I could just it would be over
um
so I'm constantly thinking of how I'm
going to die
and when I'm going to die
and that used to immediately strike
panic in me
I mean if you think something over and
over a million times eventually it quits
being as scary
um and the existential anxiety that I've
experienced didn't really come with a
lot of compulsions except for the
Googling but like without the Googling I
mostly just obsess over it in my mind
and it does cause distress
um
and
it does
kind of
stopped me from doing things sometimes
I've become really like
introverted I don't really like to go
out and be around big groups of people
and I used to
but I don't anymore
um I don't know why I just feeling like
trapped in and
anytime I get anxious about anything
really even if it's a normal thing like
if I have a test coming up it gets
replaced with that existential anxiety
um so that's been a really big Obsession
for me
and I would consider myself an agnostic
um I don't like believe in
all the things I was taught growing up
in Catholic School
but I don't think that really helped
like the Catholic School really helped
me I would freak out that Jesus was
going to come back while I was at school
and I wasn't going to get to like be
with my mom so I'd ask her about that a
lot be like is Jesus going to come back
today she'd be like no he's not
so that was um yeah is there anything
that helps it like nutrition or sleep or
anything like that
um or sleeping and eating definitely
helped me
um eating is hard for me because I do
I will obsess over how my body feels and
what my body looks like
that's an obsessive and compulsive thing
that I haven't got been able to stop or
haven't been able to break free of is um
like taking pictures of my body at a
bunch of different angles
um to like check and see what I look
like at a bunch of different angles and
then eating accordingly to how I
think I look
um it's body dysmorphia which is closely
connected to OCD so
eating helps but I have to do it I don't
starve myself or Purge or anything like
that if anything I binge eat
I like won't eat for long periods of
time and then I eat a bunch because I
get really hungry but whenever I find
that I'm really anxious
um
it's usually because I didn't take my
medicine I didn't get enough sleep or I
didn't eat so those things do help I am
on medication
I was taking Klonopin every day
for a while
which I didn't
really agree with or want to do but the
panic attacks became so awful
like it got to the point where I was
having panic attacks every single day
and if you've ever had a panic attack
you know it's like
it's hell it's horrible I was throwing
up I was shaking my teeth are chattering
I have cold sweats and it would last for
hours and I would get really scared I'd
have to go back to the hospital and
leave my dog
and OCD is an anxiety disorder so those
panic attacks just relate to OCD and
usually when I have a panic attack it
goes back to existential things like
I'll think I'm dying or I'll think I've
eaten something that's like contaminated
and it's too late it gets in my body and
now it's going to kill me
um and I'll just like freak out and
logically I know that's not true but it
doesn't matter
um
so
medication helps
I do take
Klonopin I don't take it every day
anymore I take it as I need it
because I don't want to
addiction runs in my family
pretty badly my grandfather died from
alcoholism
my uncle was addicted to heroin for a
long time
so it's just not a road I really want to
go down even though it provides the most
relief
the recreational drugs are not a thing
for you
um I smoke weeds sometimes
um
but when I smoke weed the
obsessive thoughts
become harder for me to ignore or ward
off because I'm like my inhibitions are
lowered so
um yeah I don't drink
because when I drink it just gets so bad
I don't know what about drinking makes
my OCD like through the roof but it gets
so bad
um
so yeah I just take my medication
my mom's really supportive that's really
helpful my friends are supportive people
have been in my life for a long time are
really supportive
it's hard for me to date people a lot of
my obsessions are about
or are triggered by relationships
because with relationships it's a lot of
unknown like I don't know if someone
likes me for sure I don't know if
someone's gonna leave me I don't know
their thoughts I don't know if they're
cheating on me
so I have a boyfriend right now and I
ask him a lot if he still likes me I
asked him were you thinking about
breaking up with me and things like that
and I really try not to because
it does put a strain on things even if
he knows it's my OCD it's like that's
still
a thing that I'm doing and it's it's
gonna put a strain on things so it does
make it hard
um
I used to get intrusive thoughts like in
sexual situations a lot that would kind
of stop me from being able to have
pleasurable experiences and I've gotten
better with that but I mean I will get
intrusive thoughts of children or
animals or things like if I'm
in a sexual experience and so that was
really hard
um it's just like put it feels like it's
put a lot of roadblocks in my life
like things that I have to get over to
be able to have normal interactions and
relationships with people and I do feel
misunderstood a lot and the things like
people I hear people say all the time oh
I'm so OCD blah blah and I just want to
I don't want to actually strangle them
but like I want to just shake them and
be like you don't understand
the hell that OCD is it feels like being
a prisoner in your own mind
um and it feels like you have no control
over your actions and your words and
your thoughts
um
and the treatment for it like I said
earlier is exposure exposure response
prevention so for example
if I'm really scared of dying in death I
would expose myself to that by maybe
like going to a graveyard
and having my anxiety heightened but
then not doing the compulsion so if the
compulsion is like Googling or asking I
used to ask people what do you think
happens after we die I was asking when I
was going to the hospital I was asking
the guy in the ambulance that I was like
do you believe in an afterlife and he
probably was like this girl's crazy
because they're driving me to the mental
hospital I'm strapped to a gurney and
I'm like what do you think happens when
we die and I just couldn't stop I just
couldn't stop and I was asking the
nurses things like that too
as just like a compulsive way it's just
like I need this answer
um
anyway it was um it's been hard but
the exposure exposure response
prevention I'm just going to call it
herp it's easier to say Erp Erp
um
that's the treatment for it so you
expose yourself to things you're scared
of
um like for example I could watch one of
your videos of like a sex offender and
then not engage in any compulsions
um that I would usually do in regards to
worrying that I'm a pedophile so that
could be like an exercise that I would
do with my therapist
um
to
lessen the anxiety around that and it's
basically just proving to yourself
kind of putting your hands up and being
like this thought does not hold power
over me it is just a thought
um and kind of trying to watch that
thought Float by like a cloud in the sky
it's acknowledging its presence but not
doing anything about it in overtime
learning that yeah it doesn't really
yeah it's not real it's not real so
definitely as I've gotten older with
time and age I've gotten a better sense
of who I am I'm coming into my identity
as a young adult
and knowing my values and my morals
that's helped a lot just being like I
know who I am and I know who I'm not
um and not letting OCD kind of dictate
that so things are
okay right now I have it's like a roller
coaster I have really good times where
my OCD seems to be dormant and then all
of a sudden it'll Spike and those spikes
come with like change
mostly just change like I don't do well
with change if there's any change at all
my and you feel like the uh
the sexual abuse as a child was what
triggered it what caused it I think
that's what
kick-started it it might have also been
in your
DNA it's definitely in my DNA and I'm
definitely
it's definitely wired that way in my
brain but I think that that's what
kick-started it because when I think
about it
so I told my mom about the sexual abuse
eventually and it alleviated like it
felt like
like I just had a weight lifted off of
me when I finally told someone like this
has been happening
um and I I can kind of connect that to
when I was in high school
and having sexual experiences with guys
and then wanting to tell my mom like it
having it giving me a bunch of anxiety
because I had learned that sex was my
first experience with sex was negative
as a child being molested and so I think
it was kind of in my brain like this is
a bad thing you're doing you need to
confess to your mom because that's what
made you feel better before when you
were a little kid being molested so I
think that's how it all began
if I wasn't molested would I still have
OCD probably
but I just don't know
if it would have happened so young and
if I would have been dealing with it for
so long
because some people go their whole life
or like their whole adolescent life
and then when they're around my age like
20 24 mid 20s early 20s it'll start
and they don't know what it is because
there's not a lot of representation with
OCD
so it's kind of like you're having these
thoughts that you're going to hurt
someone you're going to hurt yourself
whatever the list goes on and on you can
obsess about anything
um
but you don't know where it's coming
from and you don't really know what OCD
actually is so you're not putting a
label there's no label to put on it so
you just think you're a bad person
and the suicide rate for people with OCD
is I think it's like 10 times higher
um then the average person
um just and I think a lot of that has to
do with people not really understanding
what it is and being able to see the
signs of it and pinpoint like oh you may
be experiencing OCD you know when people
start hallucinating or having intense
mood swings it's like well maybe you're
bipolar maybe you're schizophrenic but
with OCD there's a lot of misdiagnosis
and a lot of misunderstanding around
what it is so I think that learning
about it is step one for society and
hopefully people can understand that
when they say they're so OCD that that
is really hurtful to people whose lives
have been completely uprooted by it kind
of just
get a better understanding of what OCD
actually is simply your explanation of
it might help someone yeah I hope that
made sense hope it helps you yeah
hopefully okay well thank you so much
for sharing your story thanks Mark